comme un cheveu déjà donc aujourd'hui je vais d'
abord donner une première introduction à
l'altruisme efficace donc je ne sais pas à quel point
vous êtes familier avec les idées mais ça
va être comme la première partie chaleureuse
maintenant nous allons juste présenter  les
idées clés et, espérons-le, dire des choses qui
ne sont pas trop controversées au sein de la
communauté de l'altruisme efficace, puis
nous discuterons de choses qui
ne sont pas discutées dans la
communauté de l'altruisme efficace, mais je pense
qu'il devrait y avoir plus de discussions, donc ça
va être  à propos de YouTube en particulier,
alors commençons par l'altruisme efficace,
donc c'est bien deux mots qui
ne vont généralement pas ensemble comme nous ne pouvons pas vous
pensez qu'efficace
a à voir avec je ne sais pas comme les
entreprises et quelque chose que j'ai qui est
comme le genre de contraire un
pur altruisme mais ces deux
mots vont bien ensemble en fait
ils vont bien ensemble sur cette
équation ici qui est mon nouveau
chapeau d'altruisme efficace donc je suis
je vais d'abord le mettre pour faire cette conférence maintenant je
vais parler d'altruisme commençons
par peut-être le mot qui est
plus simple maintenant l'altruisme donc je ne vous je
n'ai pas testé j'espère que ça va marcher
celui-ci ne '  Je ne peux pas travailler désolé je peux
vous dire
non hein puis-je obtenir ce son je l'ai
testé quelque chose que
ma vie est vraiment manger comme si il y a des
gens qui ne meurent pas de faim dans le monde
[Applaudissements]
donc c'est le  le type suivant de l'
émission télévisée montre vraiment vraiment certaines des
idées de l'altruisme en général, je suppose
que le fait que nous vivons assez
bien ici, surtout comme en Suisse,
surtout ici à l'EPFL en Suisse
et en quelque sorte à l'autre bout du
monde là-bas  les gens souffrent-ils et ainsi
de suite
et il semble que nous aimerions pouvoir faire
quelque chose pour eux en n'abaissant pas tant que
ça ou les normes de vie maintenant cet
argument peut être poussé beaucoup plus à l'
extrême comme il y a cet argument
de Peter singer qui est l'un des  les
principales figures de proue de  la philosophie morale en
général et en particulier dans l'
altruisme effectif où il soutient que nous avons en
fait un énorme devoir moral envers les
personnes dans le besoin, essentiellement parce que nous
conduisons comme une société, je n'ai pas la
beauté mais comme je vis assez bien
et et  Honnêtement, je pourrais donner
tellement plus que je ne donne, d'autant plus
que je ne le donne pas tant que ça et que
j'aime plus généralement que les autres
essaient de mettre fin au sexe si vous, je suppose que vos
parents sont comme des gens qui vivent aisés
en travaillant dans l'industrie ici,
en Suisse, nous étions très
aisés et avec une petite somme d'
argent, nous pouvions faire une énorme différence dans la
vie de nombreuses personnes, en
particulier dans les pays en développement,
car là-bas,
bien sûr, 1 $ a beaucoup plus beaucoup  plus grand
impact que 1 $ ici en Suisse,
donc c'est la partie tordue comme leur
revendication du désert que je pourrais faire et ne vais pas
trop m'attarder sur cela qui est le
fait qu'aujourd'hui l'altruisme est plus important
que jamais comme ça u  sed être dans
le passé qu'il n'était pas clair ce que vous
pourriez faire pour vraiment améliorer la vie de
tant de gens et en fait vous pourriez
dire que si vous étiez de retour au 18ème
siècle comme la meilleure façon d'améliorer le
niveau de vie de  la plupart des gens
amélioraient essentiellement la vapeur de la machine
à vapeur et, comme simplement l'amélioration des
technologies pour améliorer le
niveau de vie de tout le monde, ce n'est
sans doute plus autant le cas aujourd'hui,
comme nous l'étions assez bien souvent, ce sont
toutes des actions que nous pouvons prendre qui peuvent
avoir un impact beaucoup plus important
qu'auparavant est une autre raison pour laquelle l'
altruisme devient plus important
qu'avant, c'est parce que nous pouvons nous le permettre,
vous n'étiez pas vraiment le cas avant, comme
si vous regardiez
mieux le 18ème siècle comme la plupart des
gens l'étaient  pas assez
aisés pour être détordus, comment ne basez-vous
plus le cas comme dans les pays en développement
, comme la plupart des autres sont assez
aisés et nous pouvons nous permettre d'être plus
tordus maintenant, donc c'est la partie tordue
de e  l'altruisme efficace ce n'est pas la partie
de la vue d'écran qui m'intéresse
parce que ce qui est un peu comme bien nous devrions en
faire plus pour la plupart des gens un peu plus,
c'est le genre de chose dont
vous avez probablement beaucoup entendu la
partie intéressante de l'altruisme efficace
qui  celle qui me donne vraiment envie d'y
penser disons c'est la
partie affective l'idée que eh bien l'
idée clé c'est vraiment que toutes les
bonnes actions ne se valent pas il y a des
actions qui sont bien meilleures que d'autres
et il faut y réfléchir
et entreprendre les actions qui ont un
impact beaucoup plus important, surtout si elles
nécessitent le même type de ressources si
j'ai un dollar à dépenser, il est probablement
préférable de dépenser ce dollar pour des
actions qui auront un
impact bénéfique énorme sur de nombreuses personnes maintenant
ce sera tout droit donc il y a cet
exemple que Peter symbiote aime
donner comme par exemple un mouvement de torsion que
vous pouvez faire une action de torsion très étrange que
vous pouvez prendre est de donner  e argent
pour former des guides pour les aveugles,
ce sont des arbres très étranges comme personne ne
vous en voudrait, mais le fait est
que pour former une merveilleuse personne aveugle
, vous devriez investir beaucoup d'
argent comme la formation du chien  est
estimé à trente mille dollars pour
un chien et je pense que si le fait
est qu'avec le même montant d'argent, vous
pourriez avoir un impact beaucoup plus important sur tant de personnes
différentes sur tant d'autres personnes,
ce qui coûte généralement cette maladie appelée
trachome qui fait  beaucoup d'
enfants dans les pays en développement, c'est
surtout en Afrique
aveugle, donc ces enfants sont nos victimes
de victimes du trachome leurs aveugles et
le fait est que nous n'avons pas de remède pour cela
et que ce
n'est pas très cher, il est estimé à
moins de 100 $ donc avec  30 000 $ ce que vous
pourriez faire, c'est donner un chien à une
personne aveugle qui l'aidera ou vous pourriez
guérir la cécité de 300 enfants dans
les pays en développement et il semble que
si vous le savez, si vous avez ce choix
et si  vous avez trente mille dollars
à investir d'une manière ou d'une autre, il semble mal de le
donner au chien-guide alors que vous
pourriez en faire tellement plus Google
c'est là que se trouve l'idée clé de
l'altruisme efficace, c'est que certains biens
ont un impact bénéfique beaucoup plus important sur les
autres et nous  devrait les faire plutôt
que ceux qui sont bons mais pas
suffisamment bons par rapport aux
alternatives, donc c'est vraiment l'
idée de base mais peut être poussé dans des conclusions plus extrêmes
et plus contre-intuitives, donc
j'ai étudié avec cet exemple parce que je
pense que nous pouvons tous convenir que guérir le
la cécité de 300 personnes est mieux que de
donner un chien-guide à une personne aveugle,
mais vous pouvez le pousser à l'extrême où
cela commence à être un peu contre-
intuitif, par exemple dans son livre, Peter
Stiller soutient que donner de l'argent aux arts
n'est qu'un particulier à  des
institutions artistiques comme la musique le Musée
d'Art Moderne n'est pas seulement pas très
adressé comme pas très efficace dans
Toma de l'altruisme était en fait mauvais c'est
un ve  ry bizarre conclusion à venir à vous
et donc très bonne conclusion parce que nous avons
tendance à valoriser les arts nous avons tendance à penser que
donner de l'argent aux arts va améliorer
notre art artistique à la con dans la
ville par exemple qui va
améliorer le quotidien  la vie des gens qui
aiment ce genre d'œuvre d'art et
c'est vrai en effet les gens sont plus heureux
dans les villes où il y a plus d'arts mais
la question qui se pose n'est pas est-ce
bien mais est-ce mieux que ce qui aurait
pu être fait autrement et  l'
alternative à donner au MoMA n'est pas de
donner à maman
simple car le fait est que si
vous ne donnez pas à maman que
pensez-vous que les autres sont si vous donnez à maman alors
vos dons ne seront pas imposés et
vous allez  d'avoir des avantages en termes
de fiscalité et donc en donnant trop de
vu c'est comme si vous jouiez en payant
moins d'impôts donc ce sont des sommes d'argent
que Delta qui ne va pas dans les
États ou les gouvernements qui peuvent être
utilisées par exemple pour  l'éducation un  d des
trucs comme ça et donc bien qu'il y ait
un calcul non non trivial à faire
ici et dans son livre Peterson, il soutient
que l'humeur que vous faites en donnant
à maman ne va pas faire beaucoup de bien
pourquoi parce que comme maman va  l'
investir dans la construction construction peut-être un
nouveau chemin faisant partie du musée et certaines
personnes sont comme des millions de personnes
vont en profiter mais cela n'apportera pas
un énorme avantage à leur vie et
vous pouvez en quelque sorte essayer de quantifier à quel point
bon  il est comparé à dire sauver des vies
maintenant, par exemple, vous pouvez vous
demander si j'aimerais réellement dans son livre
ici Peterson compare cela à la
cécité, la question qu'il a posée est de savoir
combien de temps de cécité échangeriez-vous
pour une visite du mobile et  c'est
une réponse qui a une étiquette comment vous pouvez
trouver une sorte de réponse comme
probablement si vous allez être aveugle pendant
un an, cela ne vaudra pas la peine
comme personnellement je n'accepterais pas d'être
aveugle pendant un  année si comme je le ferais
Je n'accepte pas de visiter le MoMA si je dois être
aveugle pendant un an après cela ne me semble pas
théorique, mais comme
si j'accepterais de devenir aveugle pendant une minute
pour visiter le mobile peut-être même
quelques heures peut-être pas trop  beaucoup j'étais mais
comme ça c'est un compromis ici et si vous
essayez de le quantifier, vous pouvez trouver le
montant d'argent optimal comme le
compromis entre combien vous devriez
donner à maman par rapport à d'autres types d'organismes de bienfaisance
et c'est vraiment le  L'idée d'un
altruisme efficace modulaire est d'essayer de quantifier
tout ce genre de choses
bien sûr c'est une tâche difficile et nous
n'allons pas tous être d'accord sur la façon de
quantifier différentes choses mais
selon un senior c'est un calcul que
nous devrions au moins essayer  à faire et beaucoup
d'altruistes efficaces
ont essayé de le faire pour beaucoup de
choses qui ne semblent pas si faciles à
mesurer à l'avance, il est
important de garder à l'esprit que l'
efficacité de toute action supplémentaire est très
difficile à estimer  dépend de beaucoup de
des choses et ce sont généralement des coûts cachés,
comme si vous cédez à quelque chose,
cela aura des
conséquences très difficiles à anticiper à l'avance
et c'est encore plus difficile parce que nous ne sommes pas
très doués pour connaître le monde,
donc c'est un  extra dans la prochaine piste de
la conférence TED donnée par Hans Rosling qui
est écoutons-la alors essayez d'avoir une
réponse à votre équipe
et journaliste la prochaine question au
cours des 20 dernières années, comment le pourcentage de
personnes dans le monde qui vivent dans l'extrême
le changement de la pauvreté l'extrême pauvreté ne pas
avoir assez de nourriture pour la journée a-t-il
presque doublé le rêve plus ou moins
le même qu'est-ce qu'il avait une CRP répond maintenant que
vous voyez le mieux des catastrophes nationales dans
le monde, vous pouvez le voir sur ce graphique
ici de 1900 à  2000 en 1900, c'était
environ un demi-million de personnes qui sont mortes
chaque information du
tremblement de terre des inondations l'action technique quoi qu'il en soit
pas de tambours et ensuite comment cela a-t-il changé, nous avons
également obtenu un mineur sur le public en
Suède c'est ainsi  ils au public suédois ont
répondu au petit-déjeuner 50% pour le poulet
double 38% ont dit que c'était plus ou moins une
erreur 12 7 et la moitié c'est la meilleure
donnée du dissout les chercheurs
et ça monte et ça descend et ça va à
la seconde guerre mondiale après ça  ce n'est pas
si amusant et ça continue de tomber et
c'est beaucoup moins que la moitié du monde
a été beaucoup plus capable que
les enfants reviennent pour protéger les gens de
ça, tu sais ma douceur
[Applaudissements] ma
douce
[Musique]
alors oui c'était  très difficile à savoir
mais le monde tel qu'il est en ce moment ce sont
des questions faciles comme le monde tel qu'il
est en ce moment et si nous essayons de penser
à un altruisme efficace, nous voulons
améliorer le monde et nous devons donc parler
de la façon dont le monde  va être dans
le futur, ce qui est encore plus difficile
et ici nous sommes pires que aléatoires,
c'est assez incroyable et donc la
conclusion de ceci est vraiment quelque chose
à garder à l'esprit que je pense que je pense que
je vais tordre d'apprendre à la dure je  je suppose
que c'est toi  tu ne devrais pas faire confiance à tes tripes tes
tripes ne te font pas confiance c'est l'un
des messages clés parce que tu as
beaucoup d'intuitions sur le monde
qui dépendent toutes des médias que
tu lis et il y a beaucoup de
choses qui  sont extrêmement trompeurs à
cet égard et même si vous lisez beaucoup de
qualité plus tard parce que je suis sûr que le
sujet de Ted lit beaucoup de journaux de très
haute qualité et je suppose que
ce n'est pas nécessaire de
vous conduire dans le droit  direction il est
très difficile de connaître le monde et
vous devez voter pour que vous fassiez attention à
cela d'accord alors diapositive suivante oh ouais je
vais insister là-dessus ne faites pas confiance à votre
instinct c'est extrêmement important et c'est
très difficile mais là  il y a beaucoup de choses
sur la façon dont les conditions fonctionnent qui sont
très mauvaises
des soi-disant biais cognitifs très connus
que nous avons qui ont tendance à
surestimer les choses qui nous sont
familières comme les choses qui nous viennent
facilement à l'esprit nous avons tendance à aimer les choses
qui sont fa  miliar pour nous, il y a beaucoup de
choses qui ne vont pas dans notre façon de
penser et surtout quand il s'agit de
philosophie morale ou lorsqu'il s'agit de
connaître le monde en général, comme
ces types de connaissances sont extrêmement
difficiles à avoir, alors encore une fois, ne le faites pas  faites confiance à votre
instinct avec cela alors que faites-vous si vous
ne faites pas confiance à votre instinct que pouvez-vous utiliser si
heureusement pour nous il y a eu beaucoup
de grandes recherches qui ont été faites pour
mieux comprendre le monde et
mieux comprendre ce qui devrait être  fait pour
s'améliorer pour avoir les actions les plus efficaces
sur le monde donc je pense qu'un
réflexe important que nous devrions que nous
devrions tous avoir n'est pas de se fier à ses tripes
mais de faire confiance comme l'og la recherche qui
a été faite et surtout la
recherche de qualité qui a été  fait surtout
en termes d'altruisme efficace il y a
eu beaucoup de très bonnes recherches qui
ont été faites surtout en termes de
santé mondiale comme c'est l'
Organisation mondiale de la santé bien sûr mais comme
aussi dans diff  érents domaines comme constant
que cette association a appelé le début
qu'il a appelé giveWell qui est une méta
organisation caritative qui n'est pas une stratégie qui
essaie de faire directement le bien c'est un tableau
qui essaie de quantifier les biens que font d'
autres organisations caritatives donc c'est un
rapport très intéressant et  c'est une
chose très non triviale, c'est quelque chose que si
vous allez avec votre Gertz, vous n'allez probablement
pas trouver le bon HRG qui a
les effets bénéfiques les plus bénéfiques, comme
par exemple une chose intéressante dont
Peter Zenger parle dans son
livre est le  fait que, par exemple,
la Fondation Rockefeller qui essaie de
donner des conseils aux personnes qui - - aux personnes
qui veulent lui donner de l'argent, puis donne des
conseils sur l'association caritative à
laquelle donner de l'argent et l'une des
mesures classiques est de savoir combien fait une
association caritative
dépenser pour des trucs administratifs comme
pour lui-même et c'est en fait
une très mauvaise mesure parce que si vous
regardez bien donner ce que tout l'argent que vous
donnez  donner bien est dépensé pour
des
trucs administratifs comme non non cela a un
impact direct mais je dirais que le donateur
fait beaucoup plus de bien que la plupart des organismes de bienfaisance
sinon tous les organismes de bienfaisance ce n'est pas parce
que vous dépensez de l'argent pour vous-même que
vous n'y allez pas  faire beaucoup de bien,
donc il y a aussi cette excellente ressource c'est
un site Web, un blog et un podcast
que je recommande fortement qui s'appelle
80 000 heures et il est basé sur l'
observation qu'il n'y a que tant de
bien que vous pouvez faire si vous ne faites que  c'est
à temps partiel ou si vous ne le faites que le
week-end et en fait le moyen le plus
efficace de faire beaucoup de bien est d'en faire la
base de votre carrière maintenant cela ressemble
à un énorme sacrifice j'aime probablement que
c'est une vie que
nous devons passer  toute ma carrière à faire du
bien et à être au moins une fois et que
ce n'est pas nécessairement un
coût si important parce que la plupart des carrières qui
sont conseillées par 80 000 heures ne sont pas comme de
mauvaises carrières, ce sont juste des carrières comme
ça, c'est dur à fort impact et habituel  ly ils ont
aussi des carrières qui sont très bonnes pour
vous-même comme leurs autres carrières qui sont
déjà agréables c'est aussi une
partie importante et seront discutées
plus tard et toutes les ressources
ne vont pas toutes les présenter mais
essentiellement essayer de rechercher le bon pour
les informations de qualité qui essaient de
penser en termes d'idées quantitatives d'
altruisme efficace maintenant tous
conviennent qu'il y a quelques éléments clés
qui font quelque chose d'important
quelque chose qui mérite
un altruisme efficace pour tuer si c'est le mal
tordu qui vous intéresse et  ce sont la
clé des trois propriétés clés, donc le problème
pour une adresse efficace va être
important comme quelque chose dont vous devriez vous
soucier s'il est tout d'abord
négligé, c'est un peu
contre-intuitif, mais si vous y pensez,
c'est comme des problèmes de cadran solaire téléphonique comme le
réchauffement climatique  que vous avez probablement tous
entendu parler de nous ou que vous avez tous entendu ou dont vous avez
probablement tous entendu parler mais tout le monde en a
entendu parler donc vous n'y allez pas  pour ajouter
beaucoup à l'ensemble, il y a déjà une énorme
somme d'argent et des gens qui
essaient
de lutter contre cela, donc votre contribution
va être une contribution de plus à
quelque chose qui a déjà été important par
opposition à une table de nombreux domaines qui sont
négligés  il n'y avait pas beaucoup de gens qui
travaillaient uniquement sur cela, donc généralement s'il
y a une zone avec seulement 10 personnes
travaillant dessus,
alors en commençant à travailler dessus
vous-même, vous ajoutez beaucoup 10% de
la main-d'œuvre, il est donc important de
vous traiter  faites attention aux choses qui sont
négligées parce que vous allez avoir
un impact beaucoup plus grand si vous commencez à vous
concentrer sur ces problèmes un
autre aspect important est impactant comme
vous voulez avoir des actions qui
vont affecter beaucoup de gens si vous '
Si vous faites beaucoup de travail pour n'affecter qu'une seule personne, c'est une seule personne si vous
faites la même quantité de travail, mais
affecter des millions de personnes
aura un impact beaucoup plus important en termes d'
efficacité à risque.
Pour être beaucoup plus efficace, la
troisième chose est l'acceptabilité traitable,
vous voulez prendre des mesures pour vous concentrer sur des
plans qui peuvent être résolus,
vous ne voulez pas que vous affrontiez des données
auxquelles vous n'avez aucune stratégie pour y faire face.
et avoir une idée de la probabilité que ce plan
soit efficace,
donc sur la base de ces critères, cela a conduit
de nombreux altruistes efficaces
à identifier trois axes
principaux de priorités pour l'altruisme actif,
le premier est la pauvreté et la maladie, la
raison de  c'est qu'il y a généralement
beaucoup de problèmes, en particulier dans
les pays en développement, qui peuvent être poursuivis en justice et
qui peuvent être résolus avec très
peu de ressources et c'est parce que
ce sont des pays pauvres, donc comme n'importe quel
d'Oro que vous leur donnez fait une grande
différence cela  est l'une des principales
raisons pour lesquelles la pauvreté et la maladie sont si
importantes pour les altruistes efficaces, en
particulier lorsqu'il s'agit de
donner de l'argent comme d'habitude, l'
argent aura un impact beaucoup plus important si  vous le
donnez pour lutter contre la pauvreté ou les maladies
une autre priorité importante pour
les altruistes efficaces est la souffrance animale,
donc fondamentalement, aujourd'hui, nous tuons des
milliards d'animaux et torturons des
milliards d'animaux pour avoir de la nourriture chaque
année, donc je ne connais pas les chiffres exacts
mais  c'est vraiment énorme comme c'est une
quantité énorme et surtout dans les
fermes industrialisées il y a beaucoup de souffrance des
animaux et vous voulez aussi lutter contre cela
et il n'y a pas beaucoup d'argent qui est
déjà donné pour lutter contre cela et vous
trouvez des alternatives et la troisième
chose importante  est si l'existence d'un risque
ce sont des risques à long terme d'énormes
catastrophes sinon la destruction de l'
humanité et il y en a peu qui ont
été identifiés comme clés et nous en
discuterons plus tard ok une autre
chose qui est efficace à risqué je suppose le
plus près  tous sont d'accord, c'est que si
vous voulez avoir un impact efficace sur
le monde, vos efforts doivent être
durables, ce n'est généralement pas bon si
vous faites en effet quelque chose sur  ce et l'
oublier,
donc l'un des aspects importants,
surtout si vous en faites votre carrière, est
de revenir encore et encore sur ce
genre de problèmes et de vraiment travailler dur
dessus année après année et cela a
des implications intéressantes, surtout le
fait  qu'il est très important pour
les altruistes efficaces de prendre soin d'
eux-mêmes cela semble égoïste au début
c'est pourquoi je suis altruiste efficace pour
que je puisse prendre soin de moi mais c'est en
fait une partie très importante parce que
vous ne pouvez pas être durable vous ne pouvez pas
supporter votre faute  si vous n'aimez pas
faire cet effort et c'est pourquoi
j'aime cette idée classique si vous apportez une
touche cela signifie comme un sacrifice individuel
nous ne sommes pas nécessairement comme si ce n'était pas un
sacrifice nécessaire pour vous-même en
fait ce n'est pas souhaitable si c'est trop
gros  sacrifiez-vous pour vous-même, vous
devriez essayer de planifier des actions qui sont
efficaces mais qui vous rendent toujours heureux, en
fait encore mieux si ce sont vos
actions de torsion réelles qui vous rendent d'autant plus
heureux que vous devriez viser cela en fait une
grande partie du livre de Peter Singer insiste
sur cet effet les altruistes sont généralement
très heureux d'être une torsion fatale
si vous le faites je tordrai les actions
et vous n'êtes pas content de les faire vous  'vous le
faites probablement mal, vous devriez
essayer de trouver le bonheur dans ce que vous
faites pour que ce soit durable c'est
important un autre aspect important est la
motivation parce que c'est comme parfois
nous avons ce jour pourquoi vous vous sentez comme oh
je vais faire quelque chose  pour le monde
mais tu as cette motivation un jour mais
c'est important que cette motivation
reste car des efforts impactants tous
ceux qui peuvent durer donc c'est extrêmement
important à cultiver ainsi que cette
motivation ça ne devrait pas être comme oh je suis
motivé aujourd'hui voyons voir  quel rôle vous
devriez planifier pour être motivé à mojo
et l'un des moyens importants, le moyen le plus
utile de le faire est de se rassembler en tant que
communauté, c'est pourquoi je suis si heureux que
vous soyez si nombreux, il est important que vous
ayez tout un comm  l'unité qui te soutient
qui défend ta motivation
et qui t'aide à garder cette motivation
à faire le bien tous les
aspects importants pour prendre soin de toi c'est
prendre soin de ce que tu peux faire donc tu
vas être beaucoup plus efficace si tu
avez beaucoup de compétences vous avez beaucoup de
pouvoir vous avez beaucoup d'influence et
vous devriez travailler là-dessus aussi donc
généralement comme la première étape que 80 000 on
m'a conseillé en particulier aux jeunes
est d'étudier et d'étudier spécialement les choses
qui sont des cœurs  généralement comme les mathématiques
viennent à un sens qui est comme ça parce que
ce sont des compétences qui sont rares et
qui vont être extrêmement utiles susceptibles
d'être très utiles à l'avenir donc vous
devriez travailler sur vos compétences vous devriez
travailler sur vos connaissances c'est très
important de  cultivez cette connaissance
sur le monde entier et quels sont les
programmes importants et ainsi de suite, vous
devriez donc essayer d'être curieux si vous voulez
être efficace bord que vous devriez essayer
de connaître le wo  rld en particulier en
essayant de trouver le bonheur d'apprendre
sur le monde et ainsi que les
diplômes et le réseautage d'influence, ce
sont des choses qui sont importantes même
si elles ne semblent pas très
égoïstes et dans un certain sens, elles sont
vraiment égoïstes, je suppose, mais elles le sont
extrêmement utile pour l'altruisme efficace
également, donc ce n'est pas parce que quelque chose est
égoïste qui n'est pas un
mouvement d'altruisme efficace,
donc nous prenons soin de vous, c'est une
partie très importante de l'
altruisme efficace et une autre partie importante de
l'altruisme efficace consiste à s'assurer que les
gens qui sont  faire des
actions altruistes efficaces sont aussi des
motivations heureuses donner de la nourriture et ainsi de suite, il
y a donc tout un aspect important de
l'altruisme efficace qui consiste simplement à
soutenir et à prendre soin de tous les
altruistes efficaces et aussi
à aspirer bientôt à être efficace notre torsion
comme je l'espère  vous allez bien aujourd'hui, donc
ceci conclut la première partie sur
l'altruisme efficace maintenant je vais poser mon
cœur parce que  e Je vais parler
davantage d'idées qui sont peut-être plus
controversées au sein de la
communauté de l'altruisme efficace, c'est-à-dire que je vais
prendre cela très au sérieux Je pense que c'est
vraiment le plus important comme très
important en fait je vais faire  c'est une
revendication et ma revendication est que la promotion de
l'altruisme efficace est une
priorité de l'altruisme efficace, qu'est-ce que je veux dire par là,
si vous deviez faire beaucoup de choses comme nous
ne le faisons pas, la Corée donne beaucoup d'argent
et ainsi de suite, vous seriez
faire du bien mais imaginez maintenant que vous avez
convaincu deux personnes de faire la carrière que
vous feriez alors vous
auriez fait deux fois plus de bien c'est aussi
simple que
ça c'est une idée de base et vous pouvez l'étendre
c'est l'intéressant  partie donc en
fait la promotion d'un n'est pas je vais le
modifier en taille je vais le remplacer
par la promotion à grande échelle de l'
altruisme efficace parce que maintenant si je peux d'une manière ou d'une autre
vous convaincre tous les gars, je ne sais pas
exactement combien vous êtes  mais comme
trente personnes  dire de faire de l'
altruisme efficace comme x 30 n'aurais-je pas pu le
faire si je travaillais moi-même et à
grande échelle promeut plus de protéines, vous
pouvez en faire encore plus et je pense que ce
problème d'intensification de la promotion d'
idées d'altruisme efficace est quelque chose
qui est  en fait, c'est
quelque chose qui peut avoir un impact énorme,
donc si je peux convaincre un
millier de personnes d'adopter des
idées d'altruisme efficaces ou des
millions de personnes d'adopter des
idées d'identification d'altruisme efficaces, l'impact
sera énorme, extrêmement énorme et c'est aussi en
quelque sorte beaucoup plus traitable que  il
semble que je dirais et la raison pour laquelle
je discute de tout cela est à cause de
YouTube, donc beaucoup d'entre vous savent probablement que
je suis un youtubeur en ce moment, nous possédons également
YouTube et d'autres chaînes YouTube ou
je ne suis pas la plus grande chaîne à  tous assez
heureux de ma taille, je suis très
chanceux d'être si heureux que
j'ai cent mille ou 140
mille abonnés, donc c'est dû à
beaucoup de travail et ainsi de suite mais là  y a-t-il d'
autres personnes comme moi qui ont un
nombre d'abonnés similaire, voire dix fois
plus 100 000 abonnés une centaine de
milliers de personnes c'est énorme c'est
absolument énorme la quantité de bien
que cent mille personnes peuvent faire par
opposition à moi seul est beaucoup plus comme
est  énormément plus et ce genre d'
impact est assez courant sur YouTube comme je
ne suis pas un gros youtuber ou pas le chien
beaucoup de gens ont des impacts beaucoup plus forts
que moi maintenant je ne veux pas trop me concentrer
sur ces gars que je veux  aussi pour
parler des nombreux youtubeurs qui n'ont qu'une
centaine d'abonnés car une centaine d'
abonnés c'est quand même un nombre énorme d'
abonnés c'est plus que le nombre de
personnes dans cette salle en ce moment si vous pouvez
communiquer des idées à une centaine de personnes
c'est énorme c'est extrêmement énorme  vous n'avez pas
besoin d'être un grand youtubeur pour avoir un
fort impact, c'est pourquoi
vous vous souciez des médias sociaux en
général, mais de YouTube en particulier, qui
a un handicap parce qu'une chose qui est
p  articles YouTube vous le trouvez aussi en
podcast mais YouTube et podcast vous permettent
d'attirer l'attention du public
beaucoup plus longtemps
comme si vous êtes sur Twitter ou snapchat ou
Instagram c'est comme une pause comme si
c'était quelques secondes d'attention si vous continuez
sur YouTube  ou même savoir en podcast
podcast si incroyable pour cela que vous pouvez attirer
l'attention de quelqu'un
nous parcourons les idées les idées complexes
par exemple d'un 50 qui raisonnent
pendant 10 minutes pour sinon pendant des heures
parfois c'est pourquoi ces médias sont
particulièrement efficaces à  diffuser les
idées des idées complexes comme des idées d'
altruisme efficace désolé je pense que parier
sur la communication sur YouTube est quelque chose
qui est vraiment négligé je pense qu'il n'y a
pas assez de discussions à ce sujet
c'est extrêmement impactant et c'est
un monde assez attrayant ce n'est pas si difficile d'
avoir 50 abonnés et ça sonne nous  croyez que
vous avez 50 abonnés mais 50
abonnés c'est énorme et ça ne va toujours pas
en fait c'est tellement énorme que je veux vous montrer
une vidéo  eo par un de mes collègues c'est
un youtubeur donc je suppose que c'est un
de mes collègues
[Musique]
[Musique] les
familles choisissent d'avoir moins d'enfants
et cet effet est très très traumatisant
on constate que dans tous les pays du
monde cela se répète la population
la croissance diminue au fur et à mesure que nous augmentons l'aide, nous
prenons donc ce graphique qui montre la
croissance de la population mondiale et nous égalons les
dépenses jusqu'en 2100 et
nous pouvons voir qu'en continuant,
cela apparaît en fait d'une autre façon de voir
cela à travers ce taux  de la
croissance démographique,
vous pouvez voir que dans les années soixante, cela a
atteint un nombre assez élevé de plus de deux
pour cent par an et il est maintenant venu attendre
attendre et maintenant beaucoup de
gens construisent encore beaucoup mais la bonne nouvelle est
que la santé considérablement améliorée le
bâtard
la taille de la famille diminue et nous pouvons donc nous sentir
bien de sauver ces vies
oui, donc ce que j'ai trouvé
bien, le contenu de la vidéo est
bien sûr très intéressant mais ce que je trouve
vraiment incroyable avec cet exemple, c'est que
nous sommes h  Avant que nous ayons le plus riche l'un des
gars les plus riches de la planète, l'un des
altruistes les plus efficaces de la
planète, il donne tellement d'argent comme des
milliards de colère bien sûr et
ces gars réfléchissent vraiment à la façon
de faire le plus de bien au monde  et
qu'est-ce qu'il fait, il fait une
chaîne youtube et qu'est-ce que cette chaîne YouTube
mais il s'agit d'expliquer des idées et des
faits sur le monde cela signifie que ce
gars voit que c'est ce que son temps et
son pouce valent des milliards de dollars
Latorre donc je pense  cela montre vraiment
que l'importance qu'au moins Bill
Gates accorde aux communications sur YouTube
et je pense qu'il faudrait accorder beaucoup plus d'attention
à la qualité de l'information et de la
communication sur YouTube, d'autant plus
que les youtubeurs éducatifs ne sont pas très
aisés, je vais bien.  Je ne me plains pas
du tout comme j'ai un travail au
Royaume-Uni désolé c'est absolument génial mais
un autre est Bill Gates ce que nous
obtenons va bien aussi mais j'ai beaucoup d'
amis qui ont eu du mal  pendant des années et
ont toujours du mal à gagner leur vie sur
YouTube même s'ils ont des centaines
de milliers d'abonnés c'est un peu
fou j'ai eu ces gars qui font un
bien incroyable et certains d'entre eux
hésitent à fermer leur
chaîne YouTube parce que  ils n'ont pas de
financement soutenu comme même j'ai un
contrat d'un an ici comme non Je ne me
plains pas bien sûr mais comme beaucoup de
ma propre vie, j'ai beaucoup d'
amis youtuber comme il y a même un mois avait un
ami youtuber ayant  sa petite amie, je
pense, qui avait cette
chaîne YouTube de 200 000 abonnés YouTube où il
explique les statistiques et les façons importantes
de faire comme faire les trucs des
statistiques et les pièges, vous
ne devriez pas tomber dans ces aspects vraiment importants
que nous enseignons, nous pensons
avec quelques idées  comme il y a les
starting blocks de l'altruisme efficace ben
c'est pas un offensif tout tordu
lui même mais ouais ses vidéos ont un
fort impact positif et il avait bien
il  a eu des problèmes financiers, il a dû se
séparer de ses co-auteurs comme les
gens qu'il dirigeait la semaine de la chaîne
et maintenant il lance sa propre
chaîne YouTube et c'était vraiment un précurseur
et c'était comme s'il était il a presque créé
YouTube et il faisait tellement  bon je trouve
que c'est tellement dommage en termes d'envie d'
altruisme efficace que ces mecs qui
font tant de bien n'ont pas
un financement soutenu et je peux en donner
beaucoup il y a plein d'exemples de toutes sortes
de chaines YouTube bien pas comme  bien
comme financièrement c'est littéralement le
week-end comme ils le gèrent en quelque sorte
mais ce n'est pas soutenu ce n'est pas
que nous montrons alors l'entraîneur va je peux
je suis sûr que certains d'entre vous savent qu'il s'appelle
gazecki c'est l'une de ces énormes
chaînes YouTube mais là  il y a beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent pour vous pour Kozak donc je ne sais pas
vraiment comment ils s'en sortent
financièrement mais c'est un
exemple intéressant car c'est une
chaîne YouTube très réussie qui aborde
beaucoup de sujets difficiles  et le fait-il qui le
fait extrêmement bien comme si c'était très
étonnant ce qu'ils font si vous ne les
connaissez pas les atteindre,
mais aussi beaucoup d'entre eux dans l'équipe qui
eh bien ce n'est pas aussi souvent
qu'ils demandaient de l'argent à  leurs
abonnés, donc c'est fini si les
abonnés sont réussis à faire cela pour
donner un financement durable, mais comme ils
sont sûrement comme d'autres mots pour rendre ce
type de financement plus
durable et plus que nous montrons pour les
personnes qui gèrent ces chaînes, donc d'autres
comme celles-ci  les chaînes sont très
incroyables comme je les recommande fortement à
toutes, gigantesque pense qu'elle est l'une des je
pense qu'elle est la meilleure penseuse au
monde comme elle, elle est vraiment incroyable
pour penser clairement et et débattre
bien comme une recommandation fortement
de la chaîne YouTube que fait Robert Mize
des vidéos sur la sécurité et spécifiquement
pour AGI, donc aussi une excellente chaîne avec beaucoup de
contenus incroyables et ainsi de suite, il a commencé à
un moment donné sur ses propres demandes d'argent
aux abonnés i  ça devrait être
plus simple comme le truc c'est qu'on voit
ceux qui réussissent mais il y en a tellement
qui l'ont fait qui n'ont pas réussi et qui
ont dû créer YouTube ont un travail d'appoint
parce que ça n'avait pas de
financement soutenu et il y a cette nouvelle
chaîne YouTube  désordre chaud avec PBS qui qui a
lancé une nouvelle chaîne sur le
changement climatique comme PBS avait également une
chaîne YouTube appelée PBS Infinity Series et
ils ont dû la fermer c'est
vraiment dommage car c'était une
chaîne de si bonne qualité donc pour les francophones
sont aussi d'excellentes chaînes YouTube que je
vais recommander rapidement et aimer
encore toutes financièrement comme c'est
toujours la question de savoir si vous développez une
profession ou à temps plein et donc sachant
que c'est un partenaire, je pense en termes d'
altruisme efficace l'impact de ces  les gars
ont un énorme et pourraient être énormes, ils
étaient à plein temps sur ce genre de
projets, donc un plus fabuleux concerne
beaucoup de psychologie, il est très important de
comprendre la psychologie parce que  nous avons
beaucoup de biais cognitifs et il est très
important de les comprendre pour les
corriger à nouveau le moteur consiste à penser
clairement l'alpha du risque mais la statique peut
raviver un ultime sur le changement climatique à
partir de cela et la raison pour laquelle ils sont
très importants est que sur YouTube vous
avez  beaucoup de qualité mais vous avez aussi
l'exact opposé, vous pouvez
tout trouver sur YouTube et donc si vous cherchez une
instance de vaccination tue sur
YouTube, alors vous allez certainement
trouver une vidéo qui confirme votre
intuition en fait vous allez  à la façon de
trouver des revenus de dollars et des dizaines et des dizaines
de vidéos qui vont dans votre direction,
YouTube a tout ce que
vous pensez, vous pouvez trouver quelque chose sur
YouTube qui va défendre
ce que vous pensez mieux que vous
ne le feriez et indirect
le  opinions et pousse les opinions
des gens sur la façon dont les gens d'une manière qui
est comme massive très très massive et
aujourd'hui tout le mouvement anti-vaccin
est absolument énorme et ce h  comme beaucoup de
conséquences énormes et d'une manière ou d'une autre nous avons besoin d'un
mentor pour lutter contre cela, mais il est extrêmement
difficile de lutter contre cela juste pour vous donner une
idée de l'ampleur du problème, donc
il y avait cet article sur le Guardian
qui prétend qu'il y en avait 41
mille  cas de rougeole en 2017
au cours des six premiers mois de 2017 et il
prétend que c'était le double de deux
mille inquiets c'est plus tôt 2018
et était le double de deux mille
des saints de 2017 donc cela signifie qu'il
y a environ 20 000  donc au cours de l'année,
peut-être 50 000 quelque chose de beaucoup plus de cas
de rougeole et et comme beaucoup d'entre eux sont
mortels, nous parlons donc ici de
compétences que c'est un énorme contrôle, des dizaines de
milliers de personnes meurent et c'est
vraiment un début comme ça pourrait aller
plus gros et ensuite nous commençons et si vous
pensez à ces chiffres comme peut-être des
centaines de milliers de personnes si nous le
laissons tomber dans les prochaines années,
c'est comme un énorme énorme énorme, il commence à se
comparer au plus meurtrier
d  iseases dans le monde ce qui est le plus
mortel l'un des plus mortels
dépend de ce que vous appelez une maladie, mais l'un
des plus mortels dont
on parle souvent est le paludisme
qui tue 700 000 personnes chaque année, donc
et nous commençons à avoir  des chiffres qui
ou pas encore près de 700 000, mais ils
commencent à être gros et ils peuvent être combattus
assez facilement, il suffit de faire en sorte que les gens
attaquent les vaccins vaccinent les gens c'est un
social que nous avons déjà et ce n'est
pas très coûteux donc et je pense que
YouTube a un grand rôle à jouer  jouer
là-dedans, alors pourquoi je pense que YouTube a un grand rôle à jouer, c'est parce qu'une chose qui est probablement négligée est le fait qu'aujourd'hui, si vous regardez YouTube chaque minute, il y a quatre millions de vues sur
YouTube et c'est intéressant, c'est
intéressant de  comparez cela avec le
nombre de vos recherches Google aujourd'hui de
3,7 millions de recherches Google à chaque
minute cela signifie qu'il y a plus de
vues sur YouTube que les recherches sur
Google sont plus influencées  par ce qu'ils
voient sur YouTube puis par ce qu'ils recherchent
sur Google et ce qui est encore plus
inquiétant, c'est le fait que la plupart des vues
sur YouTube plus de la moitié des vues
sur YouTube recommandent des vues nos vues
qui sont toutes suggérées par l'
algorithme YouTube donc vous savez  lorsque vous allez sur
youtube, vous avez ces vidéos suggérées
sur la droite, vous aussi si vous allez sur la
page d'accueil de YouTube, vous avez suggéré une
vidéo, ce sont des vidéos recommandées et la
plupart des vidéos que les gens regardent des vidéos
qui leur sont données par l'
algorithme YouTube par le YouTube recommender
système pour que les gens ne recherchent plus d'
informations les gens ne recherchent pas d'
informations ils obtiennent les
informations qu'ils reçoivent et ils reçoivent ces
informations le plus souvent du
système de recommandation YouTube et le
système de recommandation YouTube est
formidable pour vous rendre accro accro
à  YouTube l'aime,
c'est pourquoi le
système d'algorithme YouTube d'aujourd'hui est conçu pour
autant que je comprenne tout le monde  ce qui n'est pas
très ouvert à ce sujet, mais il y a quelques
articles à ce sujet, YouTube
maximise au moins c'est ce que les gens
disent, c'est maximiser le temps de visionnage, il essaie
de vous faire regarder YouTube autant que
possible,
cela fait partie de toute l'économie de l'
attention  où aujourd'hui, comme la chose
que cette entreprise est l'une de vous est de
vous faire connaître à leur sujet et vous attirez
notre attention pour nous vendre afin
que vous puissiez consommer des publicités et ainsi de suite
et donc aujourd'hui l'attention est une grande partie de
la  l'économie et chaque entreprise se
bat pour attirer votre attention et
YouTube le fait mieux que
tout le monde et maximise votre rétention
il veut que vous restiez sur YouTube
et la stratégie va utiliser pour
vous faire rester sur YouTube ne sont pas
nécessairement en montrant  dans les vidéos que
vous vouliez vraiment voir, la
meilleure partie est assez souvent de vous montrer des
vidéos qui vous rendront accro
à un sujet et au sujet et à
tous les quelques sujets qui sont extrêmement
addictifs  e politique tout sur
les théories du complot ce sont des
vidéos vraiment addictives et c'est pourquoi si
vous êtes un nouveau venu sur YouTube si vous
ouvrez un nouveau compte sur YouTube et allez sur
la page recommandée les premières vidéos
qui vont
vous recommander vous'  Je vais voir beaucoup de
cette conspiration sur vos vidéos beaucoup de
vidéos de sacs vides parce que ce sont des
vidéos comme les gens qui commencent à regarder
et ils restent juste continuez à regarder ce
genre de vidéos donc c'est une bonne stratégie
pour YouTube de recommander ce titre
ces  vidéos parce qu'il a une énorme
probabilité de vous faire rester sur
YouTube, donc ce que je dis, c'est
que le monde de YouTube a à chaque fois un
vernis avec de très mauvaises conséquences en
termes d'infractions d'altruisme efficaces, donc
cela m'amène à modifier mon  revendiquer le
numéro un si je veux promouvoir
autant que possible l'idée d'altruisme efficace
le gros goulot d'étranglement n'est pas les
youtubers est le système d'algorithme YouTube le
système de recommandation et
l'IA de YouTube est capable  pour pousser les gens dans
une direction ou une autre et je
dirais que ce devrait être une priorité pour
les personnes à risque efficaces d'amener YouTube à
pousser les utilisateurs vers quelque chose comme
efficace avec certaines vidéos comment c'est en
fait une priorité aujourd'hui c'est une
action qui a un petit coût  plus d'efforts
et un impact énorme, cela peut potentiellement
avoir un impact sur des milliards de personnes presque
instantanément et au fil du temps si vous vous
habituez à ces idées d'altruisme efficaces,
vous avez beaucoup plus de chances
qu'ils vous voient me poser des questions
sur les dernières impressions je oui vous pouvez
vous poser des questions d'accord alors  Je vais en
parler ensuite, oui, donc cette
partie de cela est que d'accord, nous devrions
donc faire en sorte que je soutiens que YouTube
ici ne soit pas vers yay, mais il n'est pas clair
si cela devrait être une
information publique, peut-être qu'ils devraient le faire dans
privé
pour éviter les controverses d'accord, donc la
deuxième affirmation qui est prête à répondre à une grande partie de
votre question est que cela est
extrêmement difficile, c'est ce qu'on appelle le
poème de routine de valeur actu  Allié le nom qu'il a été
introduit par Nick Bostrom, c'est une bonne
valeur de chargement est l'idée que toute
intelligence artificielle ou algorithme, peu
importe comment vous voulez les appeler, vous
seriez mieux s'il avait des valeurs morales, des
valeurs humaines et vous devez
charger ces valeurs dans  l'algorithme
et c'est très très difficile,
comment diriez-vous que c'est l'un des
crimes les plus difficiles
qu'ils soient, mais ce n'est pas insoluble,
espérons que ce sont
des changements à la fois techniques et non techniques, l'un des
défis non techniques est généralement si  vous le
rendez public vous dites publiquement que
YouTube va dévaluer le chargement aujourd'hui eh bien
cela va mener à beaucoup de
controverses
oui c'est une sorte de plaisir difficile maintenant je
vais insister sur pourquoi ce
chargement de valeur est très difficile c'est extrêmement
amusant  et nous devons y réfléchir attentivement,
vous ne devriez pas essayer de modifier YouTube en
ce moment, surtout sans tester,
il s'agit d'un système à grande échelle, donc tout
ajustement comme si c'était une très mauvaise ingénierie
oh-hoh y  ous ne devriez pas faire de l'ingénierie en
tweetant des choses que vous devriez penser qu'il est
important de penser clairement et d'
essayer d'anticiper les conséquences potentielles,
alors pourquoi évaluer si difficile parce qu'il est
essentiellement impossible de l'obtenir à 100% n'est
même pas clair ce que signifie obtenir une
évaluation  à 100%, mais il s'agit probablement d'un
système d'apprentissage automatique, un apprentissage automatique a
tendance à être très bon pour
obtenir une précision de 90%, mais vous pensez que la
diffusion en continu pour obtenir une précision de 99,9999%,
il est impossible d'obtenir 100% et d'
accord, alors supposons que nous faisons une
vidéo youtube  disons que c'est vrai
99,9999% du temps disons qu'il
se trompe plus de fois sur un
million, ce qui est extrêmement bon, ce qui est
bien mieux que la plupart des choses
que nous faisons dans un mensonge selon les normes d'aujourd'hui
si nous parvenons à faire
cela signifie toujours qu'une fois sur un
million et se tromper et peut
devenir potentiellement très mauvais et c'est
potentiellement très mauvais parce que le
système d'algorithme YouTube prend bil  des lions de
décisions tous les jours seulement toutes les minutes non
tous les jours et tous les jours je prends des milliards
de décisions donc s'il se trompe une fois sur un
million il se trompe quand même mille
décisions elle n'est pas négligeable mais
c'est encore pire que ça parce que si les
gens comprennent les défauts  du
système d'algorithme YouTube, ils peuvent l'
exploiter comme de la pop pendant longtemps
il y a eu cette course entre Google
comme Google était comme un recommandeur comme
vous la réponse à la plupart des choses et vous
voulez qu'il soit bien classé sur Google alors
quel était tout cela  l'industrie de la
soi-disant optimisation SEO, comme si vous
vouliez maximiser votre classement sur Google,
il y avait donc tout ce jeu et il
y aura également une remise sur le jeu
, quoi que YouTube
fasse, les gens vont essayer de le pirater
et donc le  un cas sur un million
qui apparaîtra lorsque nous programmerons ou IA
eh bien peut-être que ce sera la plupart des cas
maintenant parce que les pirates vont se
concentrer sur ce cas, donc en fait ce n'est pas
un cas sur un
million  pourrait être comme cinquante pour cent du
temps, les pirates n'en
profiteront pas et c'est très difficile à
anticiper et il doit y avoir beaucoup
de recherches sur la façon d'anticiper cela
et de s'assurer que le système fonctionnera
toujours même si  les colporteurs essaient de
profiter des défauts du système
une autre raison pour laquelle c'est extrêmement
difficile est que
vous pourriez dire qu'il existe des solutions à
ce genre de problèmes mais vous pouvez le
résoudre très bien mais je dois faire ceci et
cela comme et ceci et  ceci et cela et
vous pourriez être très tentant de dire
qu'il y a beaucoup de règles qui devraient être
suivies par les constantes du système d'algorithme YouTube,
les six seront problématiques
car si vous demandez trop de
contraintes, vous allez simplement dire
non nous '  Je ne vais pas le faire parce que
c'est trop contraignant Je peux qu'ils
doivent fournir un service donc ça ne peut pas être trop
contraignant vous ne pouvez pas - pas trop de
contraintes sur les contraintes que vous
allez mettre sur une IA il y a
co  nstrains aux contraintes et et comme
une autre raison à cela est que même si
YouTube dit d'accord, nous allons appliquer
votre système, alors soudainement YouTube
va probablement être très lent très
ennuyeux et les gens vont passer à
un autre service il y a une concurrence
entre  différents domaines et si vous voulez
l'avant-garde, vous serez chargé de valeur,
la valorisation ne peut pas être trop coûteuse
sinon elle va être dépassée et la
troisième raison pour laquelle la valorisation est extrêmement
difficile est que nous allons être en désaccord
sur les valeurs à programmer comme
pair  si nous essayons de bien faire, nous
ne sommes pas d'accord sur beaucoup de choses, même les
personnes bien intentionnées ne sont pas d'accord et il est
extrêmement difficile de bien faire les choses,
nous devons atténuer ou être en désaccord d'une manière ou d'une
autre,
mais il me prend à cœur parce que la
morphine ou non, nous débattons sur Twitter ou
Facebook et Twitter et Facebook tous
des endroits extrêmement plats pour débattre comme les
gens vous avez vraiment de très mauvais
débats là-bas mais même comme en général comme
les dîners de famille c'est non  Ce n'est pas facile d'avoir un
bon débat et nous devons améliorer le
monde en débattant et en convenant que
nous n'allons pas être d'accord sur tout,
mais nous devons trouver des moyens de prendre des
décisions même lorsque nous ne sommes pas d'accord, donc tout
cela signifie que plus tard, nous tous les deux  Je veux
affirmer que la résolution du problème de chargement de la valeur
est un défi de recherche digne
de certains des meilleurs talents mathématiques des prochaines générations.
Je suis d'accord avec le
fait qu'il est extrêmement difficile.
l'algorithme est déjà là et
il doit être validé, je
dirais que ce n'est pas pour la prochaine génération comme
nous devrions travailler en ce moment sur la façon d'
améliorer la façon de résoudre la valorisation ou au
moins de proposer des solutions pour le
résoudre partiellement, donc si je combine mes deux  prétend
donc que nous avions besoin de charger la valeur et par origine
est très difficile, donc résoudre le régime de valeur
est en fait, je dirais que la
plus grande priorité d'altruisme efficace d'aujourd'hui, nous
devons savoir comment programmer les valeurs dans
systèmes algorithmiques et c'est
quelque chose auquel j'ai commencé à beaucoup
penser il y a quelques mois et comme il y a
peut-être six mois quelque chose comme ça
en juin, disons en juin, j'étais vraiment
inquiet à ce sujet et j'ai donc travaillé un
peu là-dessus  et j'ai écrit un article
sur la feuille de route pour le problème de chargement de valeur
qui présente à la fois pourquoi il est
extrêmement important, je pense que c'est
la priorité absolue d'aujourd'hui, il explique également
ce qu'il a comme une feuille de route comme un
plan directeur pour savoir comment le résoudre car c'est
très difficile  et je ne viens pas du tout pour le
résoudre mais je propose des solutions
pour, espérons-le, mieux structurer
ou résoudre cela et cela donne aussi beaucoup
d'idées sur la façon d'aider à le résoudre
sans faire de techniciens sans
faire vos recherches un troisième type qui
ferait  je ne sais pas comment, à certains égards,
ce n'est pas long, mais le troisième kam que je
vais faire est que résoudre le chargement de valeur
est également extrêmement important pour demain
car jusqu'à présent, j'ai beaucoup
parlé du degré oui  c'est aujourd'hui comme le
système de recommandation YouTube des espèces mais vous pouvez
imaginer qu'à l'avenir les gars
vont s'améliorer en fait ils
s'améliorent tous les jours donc à un
rythme assez incroyable bien comme je suis sur
le terrain
je vulgarise la vie sur le terrain  J'essaie de
me parler du terrain et
de mes instincts parce que les choses
bougent si vite et quelque chose qui a été
fait il y a six mois peut être
obsolète maintenant
ça va très très vite étonnamment
vite et nous devons donc nous préparer
pour l'avenir  a, c'est comme si le temps
qu'il nous faudrait pour résoudre l'évaluation car nous nous
sommes déjà améliorés, nous devons donc
préparer des solutions pour les futurs yeux et
sans vous, nous devrions nous préparer aux
pires solutions, les pires
paramètres et le pire des cas  les paramètres
pourraient atteindre
des capacités cognitives très très élevées, y compris des
capacités de niveau humain à l'avenir, peut-être que
dans cinq ou dix ans, nous devrions être
préparés à cela même s'il est peu
probable que nous devrions être préparés  rouge pour ce
premier module et nous en avons vraiment besoin
car la plupart des analogues n'ont aucun moyen
que les choses se passent bien si nous ne résolvons pas
la route des valeurs en Pologne ouais bon qu'il
n'y a pas moyen de contourner ce
point difficile et je vais continuer comme ça  c'est
comme si j'avais beaucoup essayé de réfléchir à des
moyens d'atténuer le risque sans
résoudre le bassin de chargement de valeur et je
n'en vois aucun, nous devrions donc vraiment
discuter de la lecture de poèmes de valeur comme une
priorité clé non seulement pour aujourd'hui mais aussi
pour le  futur, je voudrais que vous soyez maintenant ce qui
peut être fait à ce sujet la première chose
à remarquer est qu'il y a
essentiellement aujourd'hui presque zéro recherche sur le
routage de valeur comme l'autre chose est
liée à l'évaluation mais comme le
routage de valeur lui-même ainsi que comme objectif
je suis  chien vous ce n'est pas essentiellement une
bonne recherche à partir de ce moment au moins
il doit y avoir beaucoup plus de recherche à
ce sujet et l'une des raisons pour lesquelles il n'y a pas de
recherche est qu'il n'y a pas de financement pour
ce type de recherche au moins jusqu'à présent
comme le MIT a  a annoncé qu'il
va mettre 1 milliard de dollars dans l'éthique
de l'IA donc peut-être que ça va un peu changer ça
dans les années à venir mais et
quand l'autre est super mais tout le monde
devrait essayer de financer ça et
complètement pas juste j'ai raison  ici
Polly celle qui endure ne va pas
se lancer dans le chargement de valeur donc oui on a
besoin que tu t'en soucies plus mais ce que tu
fais et pour financer ce genre de recherche
et on a aussi besoin d'attirer des talents
car il y a beaucoup de
challenges techniques  qui sont extrêmement difficiles et
vous avez vraiment besoin des meilleures personnes travaillant
sur cette partie, car il est vraiment important
que les meilleurs scientifiques travaillent sur ce
type de problèmes et se soucient de ce
type de programmes et pas seulement eux
sans vous, il est important de rendre cela
très répandu donc  comme même comme je
dirais que les artistes devraient se
soucier beaucoup plus de cette planète
parce que si les artistes se soucient de ce
problème, ils peuvent diffuser ces idées d'une
manière qui peut être beaucoup plus
efficace  icient qu'au moins orthogonal pour le
faire vos achats que j'utiliserais
par exemple une autre chose qui est
importante est de valoriser la sécurité je pense
que c'est de plus en plus
le cas et c'est très bien que ce soit de
plus en plus le cas mais si vous
démarrez un  start-up par exemple, vous
n'allez pas vous vanter des protocoles de sécurité que
vous avez mis en place pour vous vanter
de la base de puissance d'apprentissage en profondeur quelque chose
comme ça, il est important de se vanter de la
sécurité, il est important que les gens qui
ne se vantent pas de la sécurité soient  autour de
quelque chose comme ça et une dernière chose
est d'améliorer le débat comme nous avons besoin de vous
pour mieux débattre de ces idées
parce que malheureusement ces idées sont
assez souvent extrêmement mal débattues
même par des experts de l'IA il y a d'énormes
désaccords entre les experts des domaines
qui sont  comme débattre comme des chats
et des chiens et très mal, nous devons donc être
beaucoup mieux ces idées et juste pour
conclure cette discussion, il y a donc un formulaire Google
donc e  Soit vous voulez que vous soyez suffisamment motivé
pour écrire ceci sur votre téléphone ou vous pouvez
aller aux événements sur Facebook, vous versez
votre lien ici quelque part sur la
scène et vous ne pouvez pas utiliser ce formulaire pour
améliorer l'expérience de l'
altruisme efficace. Non, je remercie  votre
attention
[Applaudissements]
juste une autre chose que je pensais avoir dit que
je voulais parler un peu du
mouvement de l'altruisme technique ici parce
que, comme Lee l'a dit, l'une de nos principales priorités dans
le mouvement de l'altruisme efficace à travers l'efficacité
est de diffuser l'
altruisme efficace afin que  une autre conférence comme
celle-ci peut avoir lieu alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait
donc une de nos réunions communes est un
groupe de discussion bihebdomadaire qui a
lieu comme la troisième une autre
aura lieu la semaine prochaine nous nous rencontrons à l'
Esplanade au coin de la rue six heures passées et
nous discutons des problèmes  à propos de l'altruisme efficace,
nous avons discuté une fois de la
santé mondiale et nous avons également discuté en particulier de l'
un des TED Talks qui était à la
conférence, nous avons discuté de l'un des
paniques  et les risques existentiels que cela
pose, puis nous ferons d'autres activités
au prochain semestre, nous aurons un autre
atelier sur les carrières pour aider les gens à
comprendre peut-être comment aller et avoir une
carrière très épanouissante dont ils ont
parlé que nous avons aussi peut-être un
atelier plus approfondi sur l'
altruisme efficace parce que c'est un mouvement en pleine croissance,
il a beaucoup de bases philosophiques complexes
qu'il faut s'arrêter plus de
temps pour bien comprendre avec ça Je
vous invite peut-être à prendre un verre
[Musique]
oui  une bonne question et je ne sais pas
quelle est la meilleure façon de procéder, mais comme je
pense que YouTube fait très attention à
son image et il y a des actions
prises par YouTube appartient à Google et
si je sens que YouTube ressemble beaucoup à un
La promotion de YouTube et l'éducation civique ne sont pas une bonne
publicité pour YouTube YouTube essaie également
d'investir dans l'
éducation YouTube éducatif,
donc YouTube s'en soucie
déjà et je pense qu'il est important
qu'ils voient la valeur de porter i
je ne m'en soucie pas au niveau algorithmique donc je
n'ai pas beaucoup d'amis comme YouTube
Google est qui m'a écouté et cela
peut faire une grande différence mais ces
idées doivent se répandre je pense que comme ça
ça devrait être plus acceptable d'être  croire
ce genre de choses parce que chaque fois que je
discute de ce genre d'idées avec
n'importe qui, sauf
avec des gens, je vous parle toujours mais je
m'habitue à ce que je dis
mais la plupart des gens sont très effrayés par cette
idée de l'idée que  vous allez
tromper l'algorithme ou vous obtenir donc il
doit être plus correct et pour cela, je
pense que dans un premier temps, puis j'ai besoin d'une
bonne idée est la bienvenue ouais je ne sais pas quelle
est la meilleure façon
de charger la valeur à partir de celui-ci  il semble que
la façon dont vous l'avez présenté, nous devons
encore charger nos valeurs dans l'algorithme,
ce qui signifie que oui, donc c'est un très bon
point si vous faites un
vote démocrate international, ce n'est pas la Corée qui
va suivre la bonne voie et je dirais
que même si  tu me demandes juste la valeur  s que
je mettrais dans cet algorithme sont
probablement très effrayants pour la plupart même pour
moi-
même, il est donc important d'être conscient
des limites de nos propres intuitions de
philosophie morale et donc de ce que
j'argumente pour que cette idée soit augmentée d'une
petite clé d'eutychus  qui est l'idée
que nous ne devrions pas charger des valeurs qui sont
nos valeurs actuelles que nous devrions charger des
valeurs qui sont ce que nos valeurs seraient
si nous avions le temps de mieux réfléchir à ces
idées si nous supprimions ces
biais cognitifs et des trucs comme ça alors
oui je  dirais que c'est ce qui
devrait être fait et c'est très difficile
ouais
ouais malheureusement nous ne pouvons pas bien faire
cela l'espoir est que peut-être avec un
système d'algorithmes nous pouvons faire mieux que
ce que nous pensons que nous pensons que c'est donc
l'espoir que cela soulève beaucoup de
absurdité médico-légale intéressante
comment pouvez-vous être convaincu que, comme la
machine qui a calculé ce que vous
voudriez si vous réfléchissiez plus longtemps à la façon dont
cette machine vous convainc que c'est
bien ce que vous  voudriez si vous
pensiez que c'est une réponse très très difficile
et oui nous devons réfléchir davantage
à ces problèmes et ce n'est pas clair
c'est gérable ce que j'espère que c'est essayer d'
aller dans l'autre question
ouais qu'est-ce qu'un étudiant de première année d'
accord alors  Je pense que c'est génial de démarrer une
chaîne YouTube mais je n'ai pas l'espoir
d'être vu beaucoup et la raison pour laquelle c'est
toujours génial de faire une chaîne YouTube est
que c'est un endroit où vous devez
développer vos idées c'est comme démarrer un
blog  sauf que la différence est que je
dirais que faire une vidéo YouTube
vous passez plus de temps à faire la
vidéo YouTube qu'à écrire un blog et parce que
ces gars qui écrivent des pages et des pages de
blogs et ils ne mettent pas comme si c'était très
facile de travailler sans  penser et
c'est important d'écrire et de penser est-ce que
vous écrivez et c'est un effort qui est
très précieux car cela vous aide à
comprendre ce que vous voudriez regarder
penser plus longtemps donc c'est une sorte de
productivité très utile d'un père à
apprendre  de même, si vous créez une
chaîne YouTube sur ce que vous étudiez,
j'ai appris la plupart de ce que je sais en faisant
des vidéos YouTube ou nous devons dire que
oui, cela vous oblige à YouTube
à approfondir le matériel que vous
vous enseignez donc je penserais toujours que
nous avons besoin de vues ou au moins comme avoir
un blog, disons que c'est précieux pour la
vidéo et qui sait si vous le faites
bien, vous pouvez peut-être avoir un
impact énorme sur la piste  le premier est que vous entrez
le conseil le plus important est comme
bien faire comme bien étudier avoir de bonnes notes
et apprendre beaucoup vous allez être beaucoup
plus précieux et capable d'avoir un
impact beaucoup plus grand si vous faites ça
[Musique]
bien donc  c'est un c'est un coût pour YouTube
financièrement c'est un coût alors vous pourriez
dire que d'
accord donc le coût pour YouTube mais ouais allez
sur YouTube n'est pas particulièrement bien Google
où ce n'est pas comme si je voulais faire
faillite rétro donc c'est un coût mais c'est
beaucoup plus grand  impact plus bénéfique
et comme je pense que beaucoup de gens
au sein de YouTube et au sein de Google pour que
ce film porte son nom, j'apprends sa
première chose, ce qui est un peu gênant,
mais ce qu'il a quitté Google parce qu'il
pensait que ce qu'il faisait chez Google n'était
pas bon au fond et il a donné des conférences TED
à ce sujet, en particulier l'économie  d'
attention au moins aux
conséquences de YouTube Pro, mais il soutient qu'en fait, la
plupart des gens chez Google et YouTube ont
cet état d'esprit comme s'ils
voulaient faire le bien et ils sont l'eau donc ils
n'ont pas besoin de vous qui ferait de mauvaises
choses c'est  juste que ce n'est pas
encore acquis que donc Kate tu veux faire
Google plutôt que faire ce qui est bon pour
l'entreprise mais je pense que cela peut changer
nous étions dans une situation où la plupart des gens
vont suffisamment bien souvent ces
entreprises pour se soucier de faire le bien
plutôt que de  que de garder leur poste
comme la plupart des gens attendent de
garder leur poste dans l'entreprise ou d'aller
plus haut dans l'entreprise et cela est dû aux
incitations et aux atmosphères dans l'entreprise
entreprise si ça change comme je pense que les
choses peuvent changer
comme je parierais plus sur Google c'est une
chose bizarre à dire mais je parierais plus
sur Google que sur de nombreux gouverneurs comme
vous les gars ne le ferez pas et je pense que je
ne serais pas le seul oui
ça  il semble que pour promouvoir
une filtration efficace sur YouTube, nous
devons placer dans une certaine mesure la valeur du
programme Laden correctement et cela coûte cher, donc
la question est de savoir s'il n'est pas moins cher de
payer simplement par des publicités, ce n'est pas l'un ou l'
autre vous  peut faire les deux, donc je ne sais pas
comment donner aux annonces YouTube tout ce que je
sais, c'est qu'ils ne paient pas beaucoup d'
argent aux créateurs, mais oui, c'est une idée que
j'ai continué à engager, donc il y a aussi un
compromis dans le  dans la diffusion des idées
d'altruisme effectif car si cela
se propage trop vite et trop mal comme
tout comme partager ces idées très
rapidement et pas en profondeur elles seront
facilement mal interprétées même si
vous faites du bon travail pour faire un bon
résumé de  altruisme efficace en une
phrase et tout  d'accord cinq phrases,
même si vous faites le meilleur travail
possible, il y aura beaucoup de
gens qui l'interpréteront mal, il est donc très
important de faire attention à la façon dont vous faites
cela et il y a un compromis à faire pour aller
vite et garder le noyau  des idées aussi claires
aussi claires que possible, donc je pense
qu'il n'est pas nécessaire que nous devions encore les
présenter comme des idées d'altruisme efficaces, vous
pouvez simplement présenter des choses qui comment
penser plus clairement à ce sujet comment
remettre en question vos intuitions morales
quelque chose qui, à moins qu'il n'y ait pas de question  d'
accord, merci pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]